[Music]
rah
this primal
guttural chant explodes to the throats
of 250 boys and girls signaling the
start of the camp day
but i have no idea what's going on
i've arrived at camp a week late and i
feel lost
can you imagine that scared
seven-year-old trembling in the back row
that's me
terrified i won't belong
scared i won't make friends
that was 20 years ago and i was about to
learn the lesson i want to share with
you all now
the profound impact an invested adult
can have on a child's life
for me that adult was tarzan tim
back in the summer of 2002 tarzan tim
was the coolest guy around
he wore ray-bans and a visor before the
retro look was in
he was bigger faster and stronger than
everyone at camp
and tarzan tim set out to be my friend
me
that skinny seven-year-old with more
anxiety in his gut than he could handle
himself i remember the way that tarzan
tim made me feel
feel like i belonged
he would say things like whoa mario sure
knows how to make a mud ball you all
should be asking him how he does it
or wow mario that's a fantastic dream
catcher we'll have to hang it in our
secret fort
these small moments of investment turned
a terrifying experience into a summer of
social and emotional growth
tarzan tim invested in me
and it transformed my life
summer camp has the ability to inspire
transformative change in young people's
lives
full stop the national academy of
sciences highlights summer camp benefits
on child safety
social emotional well-being
physical and mental health and academic
learning
an ongoing longitudinal study by
psychologist david yeager indicates that
a mere one week at camp can increase
college attendance rates by 18
and that's one week
imagine the power of a full summer
so the stats tell us we do good by our
children when we send them to camp where
the power of an invested adult works
wonders
but that's not the only thing i'm here
to talk about with you today
this
this picture of me and tarzan tim back
in that fabled summer of 2002.
beyond the smiles and the mud stained
shirts
what stands out to me
the general lack of ethnic diversity
my memory may be fuzzy but i'm willing
to bet that tim was the only this summer
at camp
i can say across my 16 years at camp
tim was the only black counselor in my
group
the american camp association states
that 70 of summer campers are white
americans and this under-represents the
true figure at private for-profit
sleep-away camps across the entire
camping landscape only five percent of
camps cater to a majority impoverished
population
it paid me to think about what it was
like for tarzan tim to run around tying
shoes and applying band-aids in a place
where no one looks like he did
i won't presume to speak for him
but i do know what it's like to be the
only across three years in management
consulting in 12 different projects
not once did i have a black or latinx
supervisor
team manager or managing partner
when i looked upwards craving a mentor
that looked like me
i struggled to find a business leader i
could connect with
and now i'm here at the gsb and i'm i'm
struck by this duality
on one hand we learn so much about the
benefits of diversity
research right here at stanford tells us
that diverse groups are 87 percent
better at making decisions
a recent study by the boston consulting
group says that diverse management teams
lead their companies to 19
higher revenues
better at making money better at making
decision and yet i still see so much
room for improvement
black and latinx individuals attend
college 10 to 20 percent less than their
white peers
even with a degree black college
graduates earn 21 percent less than
their white classmates
and this is exacerbated at the top
where racially diverse executives
executives of any non-white american
background
hold only 16 percent of total c-suite
positions
i want to see this change
creating and upholding diver spaces
matters to me
because i dream
of seeing people in color in positions
of power
feeling they belong
expanding access to summer camp can be a
big part of this change
i know because for me
camp made all the difference
camp allowed me to beat back that
gremlin in my head screeching you're an
imposter you don't belong
i remember back in middle school when i
was dealing with bullying
camp was the haven in which i could
prove to myself that i could be liked i
could make friends
i could respond to adversity
simply put camp and its leaders like
tarzan tim
showed me i belonged
and if i could go from outsider to
belonging at camp
i sure as hell could do it in the real
world
so
we know we do well by our children when
we send them to camp
and we know we do well by society when
we promote and uphold diverse spaces
how do we bring these two truths
together
i could deliver a whole other talk about
what society can do to diversify the
camp space
from directing tax dollars to camp
initiatives to increasing education for
minority parents about the benefits of
camp
and even yet i could deliver this whole
other talk about the camp industry could
do to diversify from targeting more
diverse camp directors to increasing
diversity equity inclusion training for
its staff
but i want to focus on the here and now
i want to focus on what you in this room
can do
to expand access to these crucially
important youth development programs
first
send your kids to camp and do so
thoughtfully
you may not have kids now but if and
when you do send them out there to play
in the woods make mud balls and stampede
through the wilderness
and if that's not their thing that's
okay
send them to basketball camp theater
camp science camp woodworking camp
imaginary skateboarding with a parrot on
your shoulder camp
the options are really endless
but choose that camp deliberately
select a camp that upholds a diverse
environment
vote with your wallet and demonstrate to
camp owners and directors across the
nation that providing an enriching
experience for children of all
backgrounds is a business imperative
and secondly
donate to scholarship programs
just about every camp organization has
its own campership program focused on
expanding opportunity of access
the truth is however many of these slots
go unapplied for because minority
families either incorrectly believe they
can afford camp or are afraid to send
their children away
certain non-profit organizations are
addressing this issue by directly
matching inner city families with
residential summer camp programs
via donations from individuals like you
and me
organizations such as the guardsmen camp
piles and project mori
pay full camp tuition so that financial
burdens don't bar children from these
life-changing programs
i'll confess
diversifying the camp space won't fix
all the achievement gaps i mentioned
earlier
even so
i can assert
with conviction
that a summer at camp can fundamentally
shift the life trajectory of a child
it can show them
they belong
it did for me
i started this talk by telling you about
tarzan tim and the power of an invested
adult
now
i'm asking you to be
that invested adult
thank you
[Music]